Das Podcast-UFO Du bist Stefan Edgar-Maria Tietze, schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Und du bist Florentin III. Danke, vielen Dank. Und das war gerade Leo, der uns sogar nicht nur in Kürze eine Premiere geboten hat, sondern er meinte auch, das war das erste dänische Intro. Das weiß er ja nicht. Nur weil nicht alle immer sagen, wo sie zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme waren, heißt das nicht, dass wir noch nicht ein dänisches Intro hatten. Wir wissen nicht, ob Leo Däne ist, ob man ihn ganz anders ausspricht, ob ich Leo völlig falsch ausbekommen habe. Leo. Da möchte ich mich jetzt auf jeden Fall entschuldigen, ich möchte nicht den Zorn der Däne auf mich lenken, auf gar keinen Fall. Das war Odins, meinst du? Nichts läge mir ferner. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid bei dieser neuen Wohlfühlausgabe von das Podcast UFO. Es wird langsam kalt, es wird flauschig, es wird warm, langsam fängt man an sich das Fell um die Ohren zu ziehen.
Es wird langsam, man hört das manchmal nicht, weil man nicht genau hinhört, wenn du deine Frank-Elstner-Aftigkeit verfällst und so Dinge wegmoderierst, aber du hast sowohl gesagt, es wird kalt, als auch es wird sehr muckelig warm. Kannst du das nochmal spezifizieren? Ja, ist das nicht das Joch der menschlichen Existenz, ein ewiges Hin und Her zwischen zu warm und zu kalt?
Ja, das stimmt.
Jeder Mensch hat in seinem Leben vielleicht zu vier, fünf Stunden aufs ganze Leben verteilt, wo man wirklich... Ja, ist das nicht das Joch der menschlichen Existenz, ein ewiges Hin und Her zwischen zu warm und zu kalt?
Jeder Mensch hat in seinem Leben vielleicht so vier, fünf Stunden aufs ganze Leben verteilt, wo man wirklich einfach im Mittelpunkt ist, wo man in der Temperatur genau in der Mitte ist, wo man nicht in eine Richtung tendiert. Wo man aber auch nicht denkt, oh, die Temperatur ist perfekt, weil das denkt man fast nie. Also auch wenn es was perfekt ist, hat man eher andere Probleme. Das stimmt. Dann denkt man, oh, jetzt habe ich Hunger. Ja.
Weil es gibt nämlich auch nur so fünf Minuten, wo man
perfekt gut gegessen hat, dass man
nicht zu voll ist, aber auch nicht zu viel Hunger
hat, sondern in so einer guten Schwebe ist.
Und es gibt ganz wenige Menschen, bei denen
überlappen diese beiden Zeiträume,
die gleichzeitig genau
richtig satt und genau richtig
gewärmt sind. Und das sind wirklich
Menschen, weil es ja einer von solchen gesagt hat,
herzlichen Glückwunsch, und ihr habt manche die Goldstunden, nennt man das. Aber es ist schon so eine Unerträglichkeit des Seins. Und lass mich da kurz mal Lass uns drauf aufbauen, ja. Genau, lass mich da kurz mal ein anderes Beispiel nehmen. Wann hattest du schon mal gedacht, ah krass, ich stehe in der richtigen Schlange an der Kasse. Oder ich stehe in der richtigen Spur im Stau, die ist jetzt schneller. Aber willst du jetzt sagen, dass man immer nur Bewusstsein von Problemen hat und dass man die schönen Dinge gar nicht bemerkt? Oder sagst du, dass alles schlecht ist immer? Nein, nein, das ist überhaupt nicht der Fall. Es ist ja nie alles schlecht. Also gerade bei uns, wenn wir Probleme haben, dann sind es ja eher Luxusprobleme. Okay, das mal an der Tat gelegt, glaube ich nicht, dass... Das liegt ja einfach so zur Seite. Das liegt ja einfach so auf den Stapel. Kurz meinen Reiswolf. Eigentlich haben wir gar keine richtigen Probleme und viele Menschen schon weggelegt. Das liegt ja einfach mal zur Seite. Dann kommen die Akte rutscht doch fast vom Tisch. Warum legst du die denn so weit weg? Ich sei froh, dass ich das ad acta gelegt habe und nicht ad reiswolf. Oh ja, das stimmt. Weil ich hätte es auch direkt in den Schredderer werfen können. Ich wollte nur sagen, klar, was jetzt kommt, ist privilegierte Bullshit-Blaberei. Das wollte ich nur so vorwegziehen. Ich hätte auch als Fuss nur danach reichen können in den Shownotes. Naja. Dafür sind sie da, lest sie durch. Ich glaube halt nur, das alles ist ein Pendel. Und wir bemerken nie, wenn wir richtig in der Mitte sind, wenn wir das mit dem perfekten Zustand haben. Aha, da hat man auch die höchste Geschwindigkeit. Ja, jetzt diese Pendelbewegung war vielleicht jetzt auch wieder ein bisschen... Finde ich aber gar kein schlechtes Bild, dass man immer nur in den Extremen zu einer gewissen Ruhe und Bewusstsein kommt und den Mittelpunkt durchgleitet man so schnell. Der verfliegt so schnell. Das Leben ist ein Pendel. Haben wir endlich jetzt mal die Metapher gefunden, um die Welt zu beschreiben, wo tausende Dichter jahrzehntelang gescheitert sind? Stefan Tietze hat es geschafft. Ich habe es jetzt mal geschafft. Das Leben ist ein Pendel. Aber auch hier, weil auch das wieder ein Pendel ist, es ist jetzt kurz der Zustand. Jetzt haben wir es kurz gelöst, aber jetzt ist es schon wieder weg. Ich möchte nur sagen, an manchen fährt das Leben ja auch vorbei.
Ja. Es gibt ja Leute, die sitzen im Pendel
und es gibt manche, die sitzen,
die sind der Kuckuck.
Der steht neben dem Pendel
und der hin und her
und die sind gar nicht im Leben drin, die sind gar nicht eingestiegen.
Um Captain Jack Sparrow zu zitieren,
nehmt euch mal Zeit und winkt diesen Moment zu,
wenn er vorbeifliegt.
Oder steigt ein, ich dachte, er steigt ein. Aus den besten Filmen, den zweiten Film. Den besten, der Perle, der Reihe. Vielleicht sollte man auch lieber alleine dichten, oder? Ich habe das Gefühl, dieser Coworking-Lyric-Workshop, den wir hier machen, ist aber auch neu. Coworking-Space, wo Rilke und Goethe zusammenhängen, irgendwie schön. Der W' Room. Aber das ist ja lustigerweise wirklich gerade ein Trend, dass Menschen kollaborieren. Das ist jetzt neu, ja, das finde ich auch interessant. Nee, ich meine in künstlerischen, dichterischen Funktionen, wie Fiction schreiben. Der Writers' Room ist inzwischen das Go-to-Medium, das Go-to-Tool, um Serien zu schreiben. Früher hat man ja Kunst geschrieben alleine. Der einsame Genius in seinem Elfenbeinturm ganz oben. Und dann einmal im Jahr kam dann so ein Blatt runtergeflogen. Oh, das neue Meisterwerk. Faust drei, Faust vier, weiter, mehr, mehr. Wie viele Fäuste kann es geben? To Faust, to Furious. Ich meine, es ist eigentlich auch eine schöne, sehr gymnasiale Sketch-Reihe, klar, aber könnte man natürlich auch machen, so der Klassiker Writer's Room mit Rilke und Goethe. Wer reitet zu spät durch Nacht und Wind? Da hast du doch die Relevanz, die Funk immer wollte, die wir nie hatten. Das war doch mal schön. Ja, genau. Das war doch mal schön. Ja, stimmt. Das ist doch immer toll jetzt. Da würde Funk ja mit offenen Armen. Lustig nebenbei Klassiker der Literaturgeschichte erklären. So. Und dann so, wie kommt das? Bildungsauftrag check. Ja gut, aber dann kannst du dir direkt die Funkkritik mit einbauen, dass du sagst, ja Reiten, das kriegt doch heute keiner mehr so, nee, du brauchst hier, mach doch nochmal was mit Gretchen, die ist beliebt, das mögen die Leute, da kriegen wir Likes, mach doch nochmal einen Gretchenableger oder so Spin-Off und Goethe so, nee, das war doch gar nicht die Idee und so. Und dann kannst du nämlich nochmal das mit reinbringen. Super, subversiv. Subversiv, so. Und dann Kafka irgendwie immer schlecht drauf und so. Ich glaube, da kann man viele gute Gags machen. Aber glaubst du, das füllt so einen kulturellen Untergang? Klar, kann sein, kann passieren. Kann passieren. Kann immer passieren. Bei jedem neuen Projekt muss man sich die Frage stellen, ist das jetzt der Punkt, wo die gesamte Kultur in Wohllose gerissen wird?
Nee, weil ich meine, weil jetzt wo Menschen mit Kunstwerken kollaborieren und man sagt, die werden rein, also einfach nur komplett weich gewaschen, so verwässert, mehr Wasser, Schal, wie wenn wenn du so eine Colaflasche richtig durchschüttelst. Dann geht die schneller runter, aber das Prickeln fehlt. Oder Spritziges an. Ja, das fehlt. Wo ist es? Das ist meine ernsthafte Frage, da möchte ich immer, dass du ernsthaft darauf antwortest, weil nicht jemand, die hinter deiner zynischen F Fassade versteckt. Da müssen wir jetzt in einen anderen Podcast gehen,
da müssen wir in meinen Feuilleton-Podcast, Florenton,
müssen wir gehen, wo ich zeitkritisch
das Tagesgeschehen betrachte, hier
allerdings nur Klammerhock.
Ja, warum nicht?
Ich sag mal so,
du kannst ja sagen, der Genius
kommt zurück, aus eigener
Feder, schreibst du das Ganze erstmal rum?
Aus eigener Erfahrung weiß ich, der Genius kommt zurück. Da ist nicht das Problem auch, dass vielleicht Produktionen viel zu teuer sind, dass Leute Ich glaube, es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,iko, ne, klar, so ein Tarantino, der macht das, der macht das alleine, aber alles drunter, da muss da nochmal jemand drüber gucken und so, damit die, vielleicht wollen die Produktionsfirmen auch zu viel Einfluss haben. Ich glaube an Tarantino. Du stellst mich hier immer so spezielle Fragen, Industrie, Unterhaltungsindustrie, Fragen, die ich nicht beantworten kann. Wo man auch meint, eigentlich stelle ich die doch mir selber, um dann eine andere Antwort zu geben, die ich mir schon sehr lange überlegt habe. Du, ich glaube, du schätzt meinen Alltag völlig falsch ein. Ich liege primär auf dem Sofa und dann niesig, weil ich eine Stauballergie habe und dann bin ich so müde. Dann bleibst du so liegen, wie dich der Nieser hingeschmissen hat. Und dann werde ich vom Nieser wieder durch den Raum geschmissen. Ich bin quasi fremdbestimmt, durch und durch. Ich bin nur noch so ein Nies-Mensch. Bist du müde gesteuert dann? Er kann auch sein. Er kann auch sein. Aber es ist, der ewige Kampf gegen den Staub hört nicht auf, deswegen jetzt auch alle Teppiche raus, kein Bock mehr auf Teppiche, weil die sind ja die größte Todesfalle für den Stauballergiker und ich habe mir jetzt auch beschlossen, ich mache nichts mehr, ich putze nicht mehr, ich staubsaug nicht mehr, weil der Staub kann von mir aus gerne auf dem Boden liegen, solange ich, noch bin ich größer als der Boden und solange die unten sind, ich oben, ist alles gut, nur sobald man anfängt zu wischen und zu räumen und zu kumen, dann kommt alles hoch. Aber wenn du durch die Wohnung rennst, weil, oh nein, Lieferandorffahrer kommt, scheiße, du rennst von deiner Couch, wo der letzte Nieser dich hingeschmissen hat, krabbelst hoch und rennst durch die Wohnung, auch das wäre ja ein Problem, wenn unten so eine zwei Zentimeter lange Staubschicht Die Turbulenzen meinst du, wenn ich mich da wie so ein Windkanal und dann links und rechts von mir so Wirbel, die das dann alles hochwirbeln. Ja, das ist ein Problem, das stimmt schon. Ja, dass du wieder aufpasst. Da muss man vielleicht auch mal Staubsaugung dann. Gibt es eigentlich irgendein Naturgesetz, das besagt, dass Lieferdienste mit der Zeit immer schlechter werden? Ich habe immer das Gefühl, ich habe so einen Lieferdienst immer gefunden. Die geben auch. Perfektes Gericht und irgendwann fehlt die Soße, einfach keine Soße mehr dabei, dann irgendwann fehlt die kleine Limette, die über den Brokkolis war, einfach weg, es wird einfach immer schlechter, so lange bis ich woanders hingehe, wo es wieder gut ist und dann wird es auch immer schlechter. Also ich habe das Gefühl. Meinst du den Lieferdienst oder du meinst das spezifische Restaurant, oder? Ja, das Essen, ja, das Restaurant. Ich habe das Gefühl, die wollen mich loswerden.
Also die sagen, komm, gib dir mal weniger, vergiss mal den Reis und es wird immer schlimmer. Vergiss mal die Hauptzutaten. Ich habe letztens sowas bestellt, so Gemüse, Reis, Soße und da war die Soße nicht dabei. Und dann sitze ich da und esse dann so eine Möhre mit Reis und denke mir, jedem Kaninchen geht's besser gerade und ich habe dafür viel Geld ausgegeben. Du kochst nicht, sondern du bestellst, um ein besseres Essen zu haben, als das, was du dir selber ermöglichen könntest. Und was du dann bekommst, ist etwas, was man sich ja selber, was so einfach wäre zu kochen, weil es ja auch kein Gericht ist, einfach so Möhren mit Reis zu haben. Das hätte man ja auch selber machen können. Ich fühle mich da immer weggemobbt, deswegen versuche ich denen immer mehr Trinkgeld zu geben, um die wieder zurückzukaufen. Das gibt euch bitte wieder Mühe. Aber das kann ja auch negativ ausgelegt werden. Das ist ja auch fast schon so ein herablassendes Äußerer mit 12 Uhr Trinkgeld gegeben. Ja, aber auch so, ab wann ist es wieder unhöflich. Ab wann ist es wieder so eine weirde Kritik? Wann ist denn eigentlich Thais mit ihrem Investigativbericht? Also wir sind ja, sage ich mal, sehr, sehr freigiebige Arbeitgeber, wir machen ja keine Deadlines oder so, dieses ganze Oldschool-Ding, da irgendwie machen wir ja nicht. Wir sagen, Thais, nimm dir die Zeit, nimm dir das Budget, das du brauchst, aber jetzt nach zweieinhalb Jahren, wo wir sie darauf angesetzt haben, auf den Trinkgeldbetrug bei, wo Dominos glaube ich, war es. Der Ruf ist ruiniert mittlerweile, auch Dominos erwartet die Ergebnisse. Warum sind wir pleite? Warum kommt niemand mehr? Und ja, Thais, weil du das hörst, Randa! Ja, vor allem, was mich ja so irritiert, inzwischen hat sich auch die Situation schon geändert. Also Thais sitzt so lange das jetzt schon aus, diese Frage, dass inzwischen Leute geschrieben haben, die diese alte Folge gehört haben, wo wir Trinkgeld sprechen und kommen denn eigentlich Trinkgeld, die man online schon überweist, überhaupt bei den Kurieren an. Da hat jetzt ein Lieferandokurier geschrieben, dass er das Trinkgeld nicht bekommt.
Und unsere Erkenntnis dann damals war, da haben alle Lieferand-Fahrer, Fahrerinnen uns geschrieben, das kommt schon an. Man erfährt es nur erst nach der Abgabe. Das heißt, wenn man das Essen übergibt, dann kann man das in Checkbox quasi anticken und dann kriegt man gesagt, wie viel Trinkgeld online gegeben wurde. Und das fließt dann wirklich in die eigene Tasche, außer bei Dominos damals. Das war dann dann der Skandal, da wollten wir Thais drauf ansetzen. Inzwischen hat sich aber zumindest ein Lieferando-Fahrer bei uns gemeldet, der gesagt hat, nee, es kommt bei ihm nicht mehr an. Vielleicht wird das Problem größer. Also Thais, unsere ehemalige Schülerpraktikantin, aktuelle Investigativjournalistin, haben wir darauf angesetzt, vielleicht merkt sie ja auch, dass das Problem gerade wächst und sie will erst mal das ganze Um, den ganzen Ausmass erstmal erfassen, um dann alle gleichzeitig zu kriegen. So das ist wie wenn du so irgendwie keinen Angesund-Kleinkriminellen verfolgst und du merkst, oh der hat noch einen Chef und dann arbeitest du dich erstmal die Schlange hoch. Ja, aber die schlägt der Hydra den Kopf ab und wachst zwei neue nach. Richtig, genau, aber du kannst, du kannst der, okay, Hydra ist ein schlechtes Beispiel, du kannst der Hydra nicht den Zeh abschneiden, sondern du musst ihr den Kopf abschneiden. Nee, nee, dann wachsen ja zwei nach. Ja, deswegen sage ich ja, ist das ein schlechtes Beispiel. Ich finde es ein super Beispiel. Warum ist das ein schlechtes Beispiel? Nein, aber so machst du es doch, wenn du irgendwie so eine Mafia-Familie zu Sturz bringen willst, dann fängst du bei den Kleinen an, arbeitest dich hoch und verhaftest dann den Oberboss. Ja, genau. In meiner Metapher wäre es ... Also klar, praktisch gesehen kommen dann neue Gangsterbosse und so. Also deine Hydra-Metapher ist natürlich in der Praxis nicht falsch. Du nimmst ihn mal wieder zu wörtlich. Aber die Theorie, glaube ich, sollten wir einfach nochmal klarkriegen, bevor wir zu dem nächsten Schritt gehen. Korinnten-Kackertum. Nee, ich finde, es kommt, was er auch meint, es wird gefährlicher dann zurückgeschossen von der Mafia. Von zwei Hydras. Hör auf, so wörtlich das zu nehmen. Ich meine nur, sie versucht nach dem Rezept die Hydra selbst zu töten. Sie will dem nicht nur, der Hydra nicht nur den Kopf abschlagen, der Domino Hydra, sondern sie will direkt wissen, wie kann ich das ganze System zum Sturz. Ach so, okay. Genau. Will sie einbuchten. Also alle Köpfe gleichzeitig abschlagen. Ich weiß nicht mehr, was war denn nochmal die Lösung? Ich glaube, was mit Feuer? Feuer ist immer die Lösung. Ach ja, er hat die abgebrannt, die Hälse, damit die nicht nachwachsen können, richtig? Ich habe erst gerade die, ich habe leider vor kurzem die sehr schäbige Dingo-Version von Hercules gesehen, diese billige deutsche Imitat von Disney-Filmen. Und da war die Lösung tatsächlich eine Maus an der Schnur. Bei der Hydra? Ja, irgendeine Art von Köder. Ich glaube, das wird mich jetzt nicht mythologisch auf die Dingo-Version. Nee, nee, nee, das war jetzt irgendein Köder. Die haben ja auch die Rechte leider nicht an Homer. Deswegen musste ich da so ein bisschen kreativ an den Griechen vorbeischreiben. Aber ich glaube, es war irgendwas mit Feuer. Es ist immer Feuer am Ende. Alles, was man nicht so normal töten kann, wird verbrannt. Mit den Bränden brannte er jeden der enthaupteten Hälse aus, sodass keine neuen Korpse mehr nachwachsen konnten. Endlich schlug Herakles Hydra auch das unsterbliche Haupt ab. Dieses begrub er am Wege und wälzte einen schweren Fels darüber. Den Rumpf von Hydra schlitzte er auf und in ihr giftiges Blut oder ihre Galle tauchte er seine Pfeile, die seitdem unheilbare tödliche Wunden schlugen. Das ist Altgriechisch, Stefan. Das ist eine andere Art von ... Ja, entschuldigen mich, dass ich es holprig gelesen habe, weil ich musste simultan Altgriechisch übersetzen. So eine alte Steintafel. Das ist nicht so ganz eindeutig. Aber du bist ja Experte für griechische Mythologie. Wie ist das denn? Wenn jetzt zwei neue Köpfe hat, sind es dann auch zwei neue Persönlichkeiten oder wurde die alte Kopfpersönlichkeit dann in zwei geteilt? Wie ist das? Ich glaube nicht, dass jeder Kopf der Hydra eine eigene komplexe Persönlichkeit hat. Ich glaube nicht, dass ein HydKopf sagt, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, are we the baddies? Glaub ich nicht. Nee, der Herkules ist der Böse, oder? Sind wir die Bösen? Hey, du bist der Neueste erstmal. Du hältst die Klappe. Ich bin schon ewig dabei. Wie lange bist du dabei? Ich wurde seit drei Jahren schon nicht abgeschlagen. Ich bin der Älteste hier. Ihr Ganzen, ihr seid alle neu dazugekommen. Ich sollte der Chef sein, weil ich der Älteste bin. Jetzt hören wir auf den Ältesten, weil die Ältesten ja immer die besten Ideen haben oder was. Ich habe ein Buch gelesen. Wo hast du denn jetzt ein Buch gelesen? Wir standen mal so, dass ich da so gegengeguckt habe. Wo warst du denn eigentlich, bevor dir der Kopf abgeschlagen wurde von Heinrich? Bevor dir der Kopf abgeschlagen wurde? Nein, du kommst ja aus dem Heinrich-Kopfstumpf. Ja, gut. Aber wo warst du denn davor? Nicht existent. Wie? Oder warst du im Hyderakörper drin und bist dann wie so ein Milchzahn, so ein Erwachsenenzahn ausgewachsen? Stell dir das vor wie ein Haifischzahn. Wo warst denn? Du kommst ja auch irgendwo her. Ich bin original. Du bist ja auch original. Ich bin einer der original drei Köpfe. Aber das heißt, wir haben im Bauch jetzt noch ganz viele andere Persönlichkeiten, die bereit sind, rauszukommen. Nein, das ist ja die Frage, wo kommst du denn her? Du weißt ja auch nicht, wo du herkommst. Na, ich bin halt normal geboren. Ja, ich bin auch normal geboren. Ja, aber... Nur halt nachdem etwas anderes gestorben ist. Und woher weiss man, welche Persönlichkeit kommt, wenn man den Kopf abschlägt? Weiss man ja nicht. Das ist einfach random. Naja, es ist auch ein bisschen Sozialisation, Umwelteinflüsse. Da haben wir jetzt sehr viele gleiche Umwelteinflüsse. Ja, ich meine, du bist eher im rechten Bereich, ich bin ja ganz links. Deswegen habe ich dieses Buch gelesen, wo wir gegen... Habe ich gar nichts mitbekommen von dem Buch. Warum sagt mir denn keiner, dass rechts neben uns ein Buch liegt? Das war so schräg hinter uns, das hat man glaube ich einfach nicht gesehen. Ich bin da einfach nur gegendetscht mit dem Kopf, weil das war so enger, als wir in der Bibliothek kurz uns versteckt haben. Das war haarscharf. Das war haarscharf. Da wären wir fast erwischt worden. Ja, kannst du dir ein komplettes Silke rummachen über eine Hydra. Aber das denke ich mir. Und ich stelle mir im Hintergrund immer so der vorbeiziehende Bäume und so vor, dass die immer unterwegs sind und sich währenddessen unterhalten. Wohin gehen die denn? Und das ist so eine Dating-Plattform mit 20 anderen Köpfen auf der anderen Tischseite. Und es ist einfach reines Chaos.
Aber das denke ich mir häufig, dieses Bösewicht
versteckt sich. Ich glaube,
weil häufig hat man ja gerade
in Horrorfilmen bei Bösewichten
so einen Jumpscare.
Dann stehen die plötzlich
da. Heißt, davor müssen sie sich aber
versteckt haben. Und ich denke mir, wenn man die ganze
Zeit, und meistens werden ja schreckliche
Filme, Horrorfilme, werden ja aus der Sicht der Guten erzählt. Ist ja logisch. Und wenn man aber aus der Sicht der Bösewichte einen Horrorfilm erzählen würde, wäre es, glaube ich, ziemlich lustig und entlarven. Ja, die immer so in der Couch lauern. Ja, und auch so sich schon freuen. Ja, genau. Ja, aber selbst Mike Myers wäre ja so. Ja, ja. Und dann genau, wenn sich die hilflose Frau dann einmal wegdreht, so jetzt, jetzt, und dann auch so, guckt er doch im Spiegel, ob er gerade steht, wirklich im Gang, weil er muss ja irgendwie so, wäre ja auch weird, wenn er dann plötzlich so hervorlurt. Gibt's aber in Scary Movie bestimmt in einer oder anderen Witzelei, in den ein oder anderen Ulk. Du, ihr müsst das hier nicht hören. Ihr könnt da einfach Scary Movie gucken.
Wir sagen das seit Folge eins. Scary Movie ist
immer zu haben. Es ist immer verfügbar.
Egal auf welchen Kanal.
Wahrscheinlich wurden die Witze schon mal
gemacht. Schaut bei Twitter,
vielleicht das nicht mehr, schaut Scary Movie.
Ja, es ist ja auch egal, welchen Kanal
man einschaltet. Scary Movie läuft immer irgendwo.
Also das ist ja, man
kommt dem ja gar nicht aus eigentlich. Nee, das ist wie eine Hydra. Ja. Das ist auch sowas, wo ich jetzt schon merke, das werde ich in der nächsten Woche, die nächsten Wochen inflationär benutzen. Ja. Weil immer irgendwie, und es passt auch immer nur so halb, aber ich werde sagen, das ist wie eine Hydra. Das ist wie eine Hydra, meinen Kopf abzuschlagen, das werde ich glaube ich zu häufig benutzen. Manchmal, wenn ich ein Wort höre, ein neues, weiß ich schon, na gut, die nächsten Wochen. Das wird mein Wort der Woche. Das wird mein fucking Wort der Woche. Das wird mein Wort. Es ist ein gutes Wort. Es ist ein gutes Wort. Aber ich denke mir, vor allem die Griechen, die haben wir ein bisschen faul. So ist ja auch der Zerberus, diesen Höllenhund, der auch drei Köpfe hat. Fluffy. Also so, wo ich mir denke, ja, erstens Fluffy, so, zweitens ... Scheiss Griechen, ne? Die Idee hatten wir doch schon, das war doch schon in Teil eins, so, und jetzt kommt das zurück. Und was ist, wenn man dem den Kopf abschlägt? Vermissen die anderen beiden den dann, oder ... Sind die erleichtert. Und dann sagen die, oh Gott, zum Glück der ... Oh Gott, Joey weg. Endlich ist Joey weg. Hated this guy.
Ja, gute Frage, ich weiss nicht.
Aber bei Fluffy können wir mal Joanne K. Rowling fragen.
Was passiert, wenn man
einem Fluffy-Kopf
den Kopf abschlägt?
Oder auch da, ob es drei verschiedene Persönlichkeiten
sind oder eine gleiche.
Es gibt doch so Schlangen.
Nee, der wurde als Hund
geboren.
Sein natürliches Wesen ist der Hund. Die sind alle drei Hund. Wenn ich sage, aber der eine denkt vielleicht, dass er eine Katze ist, sagt sie nein. Aber wer kontrolliert den Schwanz? Also wenn der mit dem Schwanz wedelt, weiss man, welcher der drei Köpfe sich freut? Oder ist es so eine Art Mehrheitsentscheidung?
Wenn mindestens zwei Köpfe sich freuen, wedelt der Schwanz.
Okay, zwei. Einer reicht nicht.
Joey alleine findet was zu fressen, schiebt sich's rein, die anderen beiden gehen leer aus, Schwanz nichts.
Boah, das erinnert mich an die süsseste Geschichte.
Letzte Woche ist es passiert.
Ich habe den Geist von Sankt Maat. Letzte Woche. Ich habe den Geist von Sankt Martin, ich habe den Geist von Sankt Martin, die süsseste aller Wochen im Jahr. Es war nämlich Sankt Martin.
Ich gebe mit seiner Laterne und meine Laterne mit mir, dort oben leuchten die Sterne und unten leuchten wir, ein Licht geht aus, ich gehe nach Haus, rabimel rabammel rabumm. Ach, deutsche Klassiker sind immer schön. Dieses schön traditionistische Lied lieben wir und Sankt-Martin-Feiertag auch. Ich wurde ja schon mal von meinen Schweizer Freunden belächelt dafür, dass es diese sehr deutsche Geschichte, die man auch irgendwie nur hier feiert, keine Ahnung, korrigiert mich, wenn es falsch ist, eigentlich ziemlich basic ist, nämlich teilt. Naja, teilt das Kleidungsstück, das ihr eigentlich am wenigsten braucht. Was ist denn die genaue Geschichte? Umhang wird geteilt. Er zieht das Schwert aus der Scheide, zieht den, schneidet den Umhang durch und gibt dem Bettler die Hälfte seines Umhangs. Und dann meinten alle zu mir, ja, das ist die deutschste Geschichte der Welt, weil alle anderen würden einen Umhang geben und er schneidet ihn halt durch. Und macht ihn für beide unnütz und sieht auch nicht cool aus, wenn du so einen heilen Umhang dabei hast. Es ist halt pragmatisch deutsch auf eine Art. Es geht nicht um Ästhetik hier, hier geht es einfach nur um, es ist schon fürsorglich, aber es ist auch nicht cool aus, wenn du so einen halben Umhang dabei hast. Es ist halt pragmatisch deutsch auf eine Art. Es geht nicht um Ästhetik hier, hier geht es einfach nur um, es ist schon fürsorglich, aber es ist auch nicht so richtig nett und es ist schon so, ja, ich achte auch mein eigenes Wohl. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel dir ein Umhang wirklich hilft. Also ist das wirklich der Punkt, wenn man ansetzt, dass man sagt, wenn man jemandem helfen will, hier, hier nimm meinen Umhang. Aber selbst für eine fiktionale Geschichte halt sehr, sehr ausgeglichen. Aber vor allem, wann spielt die denn eigentlich diese Geschichte? Ist das jetzt graue Vorzeit oder Urzeit oder Antike oder Mittelalter? Ich will wer wissen, wann war der letzte Punkt, wo man einen Umhang wirklich cool tragen konnte? Oder war das der Punkt? Weil ab dann, wenn die Geschichte natürlich im öffentlichen Bewusstsein ist, wird natürlich jeder schief angeschaut, der einen ganzen Umhang hat. Wenn das so als Symbol angekommen ist irgendwo. Oder hat man davor viel grössere, davor hatte man eine Jacke, eine Poncho, vielleicht war es vorher ein Poncho, er schneidet es durch, ist der Umhang. Oder ist der Übergang von Umhang zu Cape, dass du früher so einen richtigen Severus Snape Umhang, der einfach mal den ganzen Korridor von einem dreckskleinen Hufflepuff leerfegt. Und danach einfach so rummachst. Und da will ich dich mal sehen, deine Stauballergie. Dich will ich mal sehen in Hogwarts. Ganz eine rote Nase. Oh, wer ist der Alchemieler? Snape. Nein, der bringt den ganzen Staub der ganzen Schule mit ins Klassenzimmer. Henni! So, wie ich mich erinnere. Henni! Sankt Martin hat nach dem Kampf gegen die Hydra, ist er im Winter nach Hause geritten. Wer reitet zu spät durch Nacht und Wind? Es ist Sankt Martin nach dem Kampf der Hydra. So, ist es aber auch Martin Luther eigentlich? Nein. Okay. Sorry? Nee, gut, heilig zurück. So, Bettler kommt vorbei. Aber der war damals noch kein Sankt, der wurde erst deswegen heilig gesprochen.
Das war der Martin, das war der Martin.
Das weiss, damals war er noch Martin einfach.
Als er das gemacht hat, hatte er noch keinen heiligen Status, also der war einfach Martin.
Genau.
Kein Vorname, kein Nachname, einfach Martin, gut.
Martin wer?
Martin.
Martin, ja. Ja, okay.
Ja, so, dann ist er rumgelaufen, hat er den Umgang durchgeschnitten und so.
Es ging um Teilen. Und ich durfte letzte Woche, es war Sankt Martin, ich habe es nicht so, dann ist er rumgelaufen, hat er den Umgang durchgeschnitten und so.
Es ging um Teilen.
Und ich durfte letzte Woche, es war Sankt Martin,
ich hab's nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt.
Und man muss dazu sagen, ich muss ein bisschen ausholen,
morgens laufe ich zur Krankengymnastik,
ich habe immer Krankengymnastik, deswegen meine Schulter-Shit,
und sehe, auf der Strasse vor mir liegt fünf Euro Schein.
Und das ist der Geist Sankt Martins, später noch nicht. Ich sehe einen fünf Euro Schein. Und ich habe sonst nie Bargeld dabei. Nie. Ich zahle immer mit Karte und wenn ich, bin ich, ja, habe ich verloren, dann kann ich auch nichts machen, aber ich habe das einfach nicht. In den Läden, wo man nur mit Bargeld zahlen kann, sind mir immer Suspekt. Hattest du nicht mal so eine Klemme? Du hattest doch irgendwann mal gesagt, du hast so eine Klemme. Ja, ist auch noch einegeld mit. Aber sonst habe ich kein Bargeld. Mehr Geld, als ich je in meinem Leben gesehen habe, einfach mal so nebenbei. Ja gut, den 500-Einstein, den musst du kurz ignorieren. Zwei Zentimeter Stapel Geldschein. So, dann habe ich den Geldschein gefunden und sonst habe ich, hatte mich keinen, habe den eingesteckt, habe mich umgeguckt, schaut, ob es irgendwen gehört, jemand war da in Sichtweite, da habe ich den eingesteckt, dachte mir, komm. Dann dachte ich mir, aber auch, soll ich den liegen lassen, vielleicht kann das jemand nötiger als ich, naja, eingesteckt, mich gefreut, auch dass man einen Fünf-Euro-Schein findet, habe mich sehr gefreut. So, und abends musste ich auf den Hund aufpassen, von einer Freundin, habe auf den Hund aufgepasst und lief also mit diesem Portemonnaie und dem Fünf-Euro-Schein herum und es war Sankt Martin, weil sie ihn auf dem Schirm hatte und plötzlich bin ich losgelaufen, um mein Paket abzuholen.
War im Kiosk, hat meine Karte abgegeben,
der Typ ging weg, hat das Paket gesucht und war dann kurz verschwunden.
Und dann kamen in dem Moment zwei ganz kleine Kinder rein, mit Laternen,
und haben für mich und diesen kleinen Hund,
haben die Sankt-Martins-Lieder gesungen.
Und der Hund hat so Däumel im Schanz, war wahnsinnig euphorisch.
Das süsseste Bild, wie diese kleinen Kinder diesen Hund entdeckt haben
und dann den Hund angesungen haben mit diesen riesen Laternen.
Der Norte ist ein, der sich in der Zeit, zu können, war komplett euphorisch und hat, was passiert hier? Dann hatten diese bunten Laternen, ich habe fast geweint vor Cuteness und dann, was ich aber auch nicht am Schirm hatte, ist, man gibt dann den Kindern Geld, nachdem sie fertig sind mit dem Singen. Wusste ich nicht genau, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe, glaube ich, nie Geld dem Männertein gesagt. Keine Ahnung. Alles bis hier ist mir fremd, aber ja. Hab gedacht, krass, ich habe in die Kleingeld, Shit, was mache ich jetzt? Vielmehr nach, ich bin einen Fünf-Euro-Schein. Das waren zwei kleine Mädchen. Ich habe einer von beiden den Fünf-Euro-Schein gegeben. Und sie haben sich ja gefreut, dann sind sie nach außen gegangen, ich habe gesagt, Gott sei Dank habe ich diesen fünf Euro-Schein heute Morgen eingepackt, wie geil, jetzt endlich alles geht full circle, alles macht Sinn und dann gehe ich, bekomme mein Paket, gehe raus, dachte mir, ja der Kioskbesitzer ist aber gut raus und kam aus der ganzen Nummer, musste den nicht, war die ganze Zeit hinten mein Paket gesucht. Der wartet noch so hinten im Raum, bis sie aufhören zu singen. Ja, genau. Und dann kam ich wieder raus und dann war
großer Streit.
Die beiden Mädels, die kleinen,
haben sich gestritten, weil
die eine den Fünf-Euro-Schein bekommen hat.
Ich finde es so geil, so komplett auch den Act
fallen gelassen, so Zigarette auch.
So, was haben wir, ha?
Was war das denn jetzt wieder?
Du brauchst doch nicht den Scheiß Köter anzusingen, die hat doch kein Geld dabei. Mein Gott, Bianca, reiss dich zusammen. Ich habe dir gesagt, den Typen, den Typen an den Singen. Und jetzt zeig mal ein bisschen mehr Knöchel. Und dann war ein Mädchen ganz traurig, weil sie den fünf Euro schon nicht hat. Und die anderen schon. Und dann zog sie ihr Schwert.
Und ich kam raus und hab gesagt,
so, jetzt gibst du einfach
2,50 Euro
von deinen Geldstücken
gibst es ihr, sie gibt dir den 5er
und ihr habt beide
2,50 Euro bekommen.
Und bin gegangen
und sie haben gesagt, ja, macht Sinn, klar,
auf die Idee kam sie nicht. Auf die Idee kam sie nicht nicht die waren noch ganz klein die waren richtig ganz okay sie waren so klein dass sie barely glaube ich die wörter kennen von dem text gerade sichtliches alphabet getastet haben ja ganz ganz klein laufen fällt ihnen schwer die arme nutzlos an den seiten herunter baumelnd aber es war so was soll. Alles war irritierend in dieser Szene, dieser kleine, sechs Monate alte Hund, diese kleinen, sechs Monate alten Mädels mit den riesen Laternen, die fast vorne rüberkommen. Nach der Krankengymnastik. Ich. Mit Paket unterm Arm, diesem Hund, was ein neues Phänomen für mich ist. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja so und so, mach das am besten. Und dann habe habe ich den Mittleren und dann so Geldklappern hören, haben sie es ausgetauscht. Und dann dachte ich mir, das reicht auch von dem Moment, ich habe denen das Prinzip des Teilens erklärt. Sankt Stephan. Nein. Sankt Stephan. Nein, nein, nein. Vatikan. Es ist noch Deutscher. Wo ist er? Ich habe nicht, doch, na gut, aber es ist so, ich habe nicht geteilt, ich hab einfach nur einer Person etwas gegeben und sie mussten dann selber teilen lernen. Ja. Das eine Mädels war dann quasi ... Es ist die kompliziertere Moral. Also du gibst es den Bedürftigen und sorgst dann, dass die das unter sich richtig teilen, das ist schon eine merkwürdige Moral. Vor allem, weil du ein Paket auch unterm Arm hattest. Also du hattest ja auch was von dir dabei, während die ja unbedingt was haben wollten. Ich dachte kurz, die Geschichte biegt in eine andere Richtung ab. Und dann habe ich gesagt, dann nimm du fünf Euro und hier hast du mein Paket. Ach so. Man macht die mal wieder. Nee, aber hier ist ein Hund. Oh ja. Nee, aber ich dachte mir runtergegebrochen, Sankt Martin, es geht darum, zu teilen.
Ja.
Und ich habe den beiden zum ersten Mal in ihrem kleinen, kurzen Leben gezeigt, wie man teilt.
Und das fand ich irgendwie eine schöne Sache.
Ich finde es irgendwie eine herzerwärmende Geschichte.
Ich finde es auch eine schöne Geschichte, es ist eine runde Nummer.
Auf jeden Fall auch mit dem Fünf-Euro-Schein, den sie vielleicht vorhin selber verloren hatten, kann man ja dann irgendwie nach den Credits nochmal so eine kleine Szene zeigen. Nee, nee, das eine war ganz ganz früh morgens, das andere war ganz ganz spät abends. Ja, vielleicht mussten die auch zur Schule oder so und haben das dann dem Abgenommen oder so. Das wäre auf jeden Fall. Also das würde mich jetzt noch interessieren, wo der hergekommen ist, ob der auch noch mal von irgendwo gekommen ist oder so. Ignorieren.
Ja, nee, der lag ja nicht umsonst da so. Das ist ja Chekhovs Schein so, wenn der da liegt, dann muss der auch irgendwie.
Ja, ich finde ja keine Geschichte, das ist ja passiert.
Nee, ich habe mich sehr gefreut, es war eine herzwerbende Geschichte.
Das ist dein heiligen Moment, ja dann habe ich denen gesagt, wenn du dir zwei Euro fünfzig gibst und sie gibt dir den Schein, dann habt ihr beide zwei Euro fünfzig, habt ihr geteilt. Danke Stefan. Sankt Martin, Sankt Martin, 50 Prozent vom Schein. Es gibt ja auch noch den Song, es gibt ja nicht nur Rebimel, Rabammel, Rabum, Rabimel, Rabamml", sondern es gibt ja auch noch ,,Sank Martin", ,,Sank Martin", ,,Sank Martin", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,,Den", ,, ,,Den", ,, ,,Den", irgendwie, aber ich bin mir auch nicht mehr hundertprozentig sicher, ob ich das verwechsel mit Stuck oder was anderem oder so. Ich bin lost in was, was das angeht. So teilen, das ist nicht unser Ding, aber es ist eine schwierige Angelegenheit. Das war irre. Also ich muss sagen, ich bin großer Fan von diesem Fest. Es laufen immer so Blaskapellen dann durch Köln und singen Sankt Martins Lieder und überall sind so ganz kleine Kinder mit riesen Laternen und laufen mit den Eltern rum. Ich finde das toll. Ich finde auch so Nachtspatz-Sinkend finde ich auch toll. Ja, vor allem in derer Zeit ist ja nachts irgendwie 19 Uhr. Da kannst du mit den Kindern mal nachts raus und trotzdem irgendwie noch vor Pink Panther ins Bett. Und falls ihr Liederschreiber seid, so ein klassischer altdeutscher Liederschreiber, so Hoffmannsthal oder sowas, wenn ihr das seid, dann schreibt doch gerne mal auch ein zeitgenössisches Sankt-Stephans-Lied. Gieß doch mal diese herzerwärmende und moral getränkte Geschichte auch gerne mal in Verse, dass wir das wirklich verewigen können und vielleicht eines Tages singen wir den Sankt-Stephans-Tag und dann ich meine, wenn du noch lebst zu der Zeit, ich weiß nicht, ob man als Heiliger da auch Einfluss hat. Aber können wir dann auch so einen Fünf-Euro-Schein mehr machen? Mir ging das auch gar nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das inflationsbereinigt irgendwie. Deswegen gibt es in diesen Geschichten oft wenig konkrete Beträge, sondern eher der Umhang oder. Aus dem Teddy, der Teddy-Umhang. Aber was ich. Fische wird geteilt, Rotleib. Mir wird das jetzt zu ... Ich wollte mit der Geschichte nicht erzählen, wie heroisch mein Handeln war. Genau deine Bescheidenheit ist ja Teil deines Heiligenkults. Nein, ich möchte mit der Geschichte nur sagen, der Geist Sankt Martins ist mir erschienen, weil ich diesen noch sehr jungen Menschen das Prinzip des Teilens erklären konnte. Welche Rolle hatte der Hund? Also steht der dann irgendwie ... Das war einfach nur ... Kann man den nicht rauskürzen? Den kannst du auch rauskürzen. Gar nicht so wichtig. Aber der könnte im Refrain dann noch so. Aber ich glaube, die Mädels wären gar nicht bei mir schön geblieben. Der Hund sah, dass es gut war. So, vielleicht ist das ja der Geist von Sankt Martin in dem Hund drin oder so. Vielleicht kann man das ja noch. Ich denke jetzt ans Lied, ich denke an die Verfilmung. Das Pferd brauchst du ja auch nicht. Weißt du, wie viele Pferde keinen Job haben im Jahr und dann nur für Sankt Martins gebucht werden? Das Bild, du reichst von oben etwas nach unten, das ist doch das zentrale Bild. Ja, stellt euch mich vor auf dem Hund reitend. Da macht er vielleicht wieder Sinn. Ich finde, das Fert kannst du auch rauskürzen, kann auch ein grosser Mann sein. Ja. Ich dachte, und wo kommen die Laternen her? Das ist auch wieder so Ostereige Geschichte. Was stockdunkel ist oder so. Was stockdunkel oder nachts sonst ist. Ich habe jedenfalls gedacht, es war halt noch mal doppelt süss und wahrscheinlich wären die gar nicht bei mir stehen geblieben, wenn der Hund nicht da gewesen wäre. Und die waren beide sehr angetan. Und ich glaube nicht, dass die bei mir stehen geblieben wären, so ein grosser, miesklaunter Mann. Ich glaube, du bist auch der einzige Mensch, der wirklich einmal diese Situation genossen hat, dass man ein Lied gesungen bekommt. Ich glaube, das ist allgemein eine der unangenehmsten Situationen überhaupt. Ja, aber das versteht... Einfach so diese Empfängerposition des, ja, okay, ja, es ist super unangenehm. Oh, noch eine Strophe, noch eine Strophe. Ich wurde auch sofort instant so richtig rot und habe angefangen zu schwitzen, aber der Hund hat halt geholfen, weißt du? Der ist halt dabei, der hört zu, sie haben den entdeckt, haben für den gesungen und er hat sich da hingesetzt, was natürlich schon eine Geste ist. Hunde stehen auf vier Beinen, das ist deren Stand. Und dann setzt er sich hin, um zu gucken, was passiert. Also er lässt sich dann sozusagen aufs Menschliche nieder, weil er hat dann auch nur noch zwei Beine. Genau. Und ich hab dann quasi mit dem Hund zusammen ... Der erlebt das auch alles zum ersten Mal, Sankt Martin. Ich verstehe, ja, okay. Und in gewisser Weise hat es mich beruhigt. Gut ausgebildete Hund, dass er so reagiert hat. Hätte natürlich auch eine ganz andere Geschichte werden können, wenn der jetzt ausrastet und die Mädchen anbellt und beisst. Er war kurz davor, in Laterne zu beissen. Aber das habe ich jetzt mal ausgelassen, for the sake of the story. Schöne Geschichte. Ich bin gespannt, ob wir da liedermacherische Aufarbeitungen bekommen. Aber so richtig, aber so wirklich so altertümlich. Ja, ja, genau. So richtig, dass alle mitsingen können, So auch mit immer wieder wiederholt und nochmal Laterne. Warum leuchten die Sterne und unten leuchten wir? Das ist ein super Satz, ein super Lyric einfach. Oben leuchten die Sterne, weil es ist Nacht und unten leuchten wir, weil wir haben Laternen. Aber es fängt ja schon genial an. Ich gehe mit meiner Laterne und meine Laterne mit mir. Ja, genau, dieses Spiegelthema haben wir immer schon mit drin. Aber ich wirkt gegen mich. Die Laterne in diesem Sinne. Ja, ich verstehe schon. Und es ist ja auch so lustig, weil man sieht ja wirklich, das sind ja ganz kleine Kinder mit riesigen Laternen. Man weiss ja wirklich nicht, wer hier wen führt. Ja, das stimmt. Wie so mit kleinen Hunden so, wo der Hund eher dann das Kindgassi führt. Genau, genau. Und das ist natürlich schon, deswegen geht meine Lateinigung mit mir, finde ich natürlich, macht ja gar keinen Sinn, semantisch. Ne, es ist eine schöne Sache auf jeden Fall. Und ich weiß gar nicht, wie das ist, also wenn du jetzt wirklich heilig gesprochen werden wirst, hast du dann Einfluss über deinen Verehrungskult, kannst du da sagen, kannst du nochmal übers Lied drüber gucken oder so oder diese heiligen Inschrift und so, kannst du das dann alles nochmal korrigieren? Ich glaube, man muss erstmal auch tot sein, um heilig gesprochen werden zu können. Also du wirst es nicht mehr erfahren. Ich würde meinen Tod inszenieren, um noch ... Ich bin so narzisstisch, dass ich gerne sehen würde, wie mein Verehrer tun.
Ja, aber ist ja die Frage, also kriegt man dann so einen Schein ausgestellt,
hier, sobald sie sterben, werden sie heilig gesprochen, dein Papst, oder ist es wirklich so, weil ich meine, das hat sich doch rumgesprochen im Vatikan, und dann sagen sie so, oh, jetzt wirst du vielleicht bis sobald sterben. Die machen so Hints, meinst du? Ja, genau, die haben dann schon so eine leere Steinplakette im Vatikan. You guys! Franziskus hat gesagt, ich soll nichts sagen, aber das sieht ganz gut aus. Wirklich? Das sieht ganz gut aus. Dann muss ich nur noch sterben. Aber gute Frage. Habe ich dann so Einfluss auf welcher Tag ist das? Weil ich will ja nicht im Sommer verkehrt. Nee, du wirst schön, wenn alle eingepackt sind.
Schön, wenn es dunkel ist.
Du finierst deinen Tod, aber dann
als Heiliger wird deine Körper natürlich
auch zur Reliquie, also dir wird dann Teil
der Verehrung und dann dein Fingernagel
und dein Zehenknochen und so
wird dann irgendwie in Malmö in der
Kathedrale ausgestellt.
Wie handhabst du das, also wen willst
du da als Leiche dann?
Weil dein Körper ist ja dann auch, sag ich mal, wichtig. Der wird ja nicht einfach nur vergraben. Da brauchst du ja wirklich eine Leiche dann. Das stimmt schon. Wo kriegst du die denn her? Meinst du, dass du drei Hunde zusammenbinden kannst und dann denkt man, das ist ein Menschenskelett? Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Das steht ja außer Frage. Ja, aber ich denke auch so.
Also es gibt auch noch zwei weitere Hunde.
Aber im Kölner Dom sind ja auch nicht wirklich die Gebeine der Heiligen drei Kölner. Ja, aber es müssen ja irgendwelche Gebeine sein. Ja, aber das wissen wir auch nicht. Hast du schon mal ein Gebein im Kölner Dom gesehen? Ich habe da schon mal so Reliquien gesehen, das ist dann so ein riesiger Kerzenhalter, wo in der Mitte dann so eine Glaskapsel ist, wie so ein Kaugummiautomat. Und da siehst du dann so ein Knochen. Aber gut, ich kann jetzt auch nicht ein Knochen von einem Stück Holz unterscheiden auf Sicht, aber irgendwas müssen da sein. Ich sag dir eins, das können die meisten nicht. Das können die meisten nicht. Und deswegen? Ja, ja, okay, wenn die ein Stück Holz, Nast vergraben. Naja, wir denken darüber nach. Mir ging es jetzt aber auch gar nicht so sehr darum, mich als Held, als Sankt Stephanus zu beizumieren. Das macht dich ja so anbetungswürdig, das macht dich ja so unwiderstehlich anbetungswürdig. Ich werde dich heute verehrten. Wollen wir das eigentlich mal einreichen als mein erstes Wunder im Vatikan? Stimmt, es braucht ja zwei. Was war das Wunder? Ja, aber kann man auf der Website, muss man dann, wird das dann rot markiert?
Also erstmal Cookies akzeptieren. Ja, genau, so. Erstmal Horstien akzeptieren. Aber, und dann kann man ja, da muss man ja in 140 Zeichen das erste, die Wunder jeweils dann, aber kann ich das erste schon mal hinschicken oder muss ich, kann ich das erst ausfüllen, das Formular, wenn ich zwei Wunder, weil man braucht ja zwei Wunder im Herzen. Ich glaube, du kriegst eins.
Es ist halt auch die falsche Motivation.
Wenn du weisst, du hast ein bestätigtes Wunder vom Vatikan,
dann ist halt die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch, dass du das zweite fälschst. Das glaube ich, wissen die auch. Von daher glaube ich, ist es eine berechtigte Frage, dass die dich überhaupt erst in Erwägung ziehen, wenn du überhaupt zwei hast. Also Formular kann ich nicht abschicken. Machen Sie zur Sicherheit mal drei Wunder, dann können wir da drüber gucken und dann können wir, wenn sich rausstellt, dass eins nur so halb gar ist, wer weiß ja, vielleicht so ein halbes protestantisches Wunder, da wollen wir gar nichts mit zu tun haben. Der fünf Euro schon nicht gefunden hat. Richtig. Kann man jetzt auch schon an sich als Wunder. Unabhängig von dieser Sankt Martin. Naja, hat der irgendwie gebrannt oder so? Oder zu ihm gesprochen? Nee, er lag auf dem Gehsteig. Und war da irgendwie, also ist da,
haben sich die Himmelstore geöffnet.
Die Himmelstore haben sich ein bisschen geöffnet.
Leicht geöffnet?
Es war blauer Himmel.
Gekippt?
Es hat schon, also Himmelstore waren,
ich weiß nicht, wie Sie das genau definieren,
aber die Sonne hat schon mehr auf den Schoß.
Schoot ihr auf den Schoß?
Hm, ich bräuchte noch, tut mir leid, ich brauch da mehr. Engelschoräle, sowas in der Richtung, Fanfaren, himmlische Harmonie des Universums, Götterklänge, sowas in der Ecke. Nee, müsste ich lügen. Gar nichts. Müsste ich jetzt lügen. Ja, nee, das machen wir lieber nicht. An ihrem Körper Blutwunden, plötzlich aufspringende Blutwunden an den Händen, sowas in der Richtung. Nee, nicht, dass ich, aber meine Schulter, da habe ich so einen riesen Nabel, das war wegen dem E-Scooter-Unfall. Da hat ihn ein römischer Soldat reingestochen, oder? Nee, da kann man schon sagen, ein Schutzengel, ein Schutzengel hat mich da, das hätte ja auch Schlimmeres passieren können, hat mich da am Mediapark geschützt. Wie haben Sie sich das zugezogen? Also das war im Pontius Pilatus? E-Scooter-Unfall. Uff, da müsste ich noch mal
jetzt in den alten Apogryphen
nachschauen.
Ja, also ich sag mal so.
Ich nehm das jetzt mal hier auf in den
Computer, ich schreib das mal rein.
Das haben wir die letzte Mal nämlich auch schon.
Und dann schauen wir mal und dann melden wir uns
bei Ihnen. Und dann melde ich mich einfach
wieder unter dem gleichen Gebet.
Gleiches Gebet, gleiche Zeit und
wie gesagt, das mit dem Lügen, das lassen wir.
Und dann kommen wir zu Ihnen zurück.
Okay, Amen.
Gott mit Ihnen, bis dann. Amen.
Tschüss.
Nee, nach dem Armen kann nichts wegkommen.
Und Schatz, hat's geklappt?
Ja, ist ja wieder auf Wiedervorlage.
Mensch, mach dir nichts draus, Mensch. Das nächste Mal klaatscht bestimmt. Danke, Maria. Maria Magdalena. Gerne. Soll ich dir noch ein Lied singen? Singen wir noch mal mein Lied. Der heilige Stefan, der sieht einen Stern. Weiter ist es noch nicht. Du hast den ganzen Tag. Du machst nichts. Ich muss hier immer in diesen Warteläumen rumsitzen. Ich bring die Wunder nach Hause, du machst nichts. Also das ist jetzt auch nicht, Macher, wie nicht, nicht gar nicht. Doch. Ich muss den ganzen Tag Leichen ausgraben für dich, damit du deine scheiß Reniquie am Ende hast. Ja, dein Gebein.
Du bist zu klein, du bist zu groß.
So eine Ahnung, wie viele tatsächliche
Leichen es auf Friedhöfen gibt, kaum.
Jedes Grab ist leer.
Wo sind die denn eigentlich alle?
B-Plot, Zombie und so.
Mein Schlüsselbein ist gebrochen.
Du musst also nicht irgendwelche Gebeine,
nicht irgendwelche Gebeine.
Genau, wir nehmen dein gebrochenes Schlüsselbein. Das ist die Hauptreligie, das stimmt, wofür du bekannt bist. Ja, richtig gut. Schlüsselbein ist doch perfekt. Schlüsselgebein. Super. Sehr gut. Haben wir es, haben wir abgehakt. Sehr schön. Heiligen Anmeldung ist damit durch. Sehr gut. Ja, immer noch eine große, ja, also neben der Riemannschen Vermutung, die wir beweisen wollen, und um endlich mal eine Million Dollar zu bekommen, wollen wir ja immer noch einen von euch, einer der Hörerinnen und Hörer vom Podcast UFO heilig gesprochen haben. Mindestens einen. Und deswegen also immer noch, der Aufruf gilt, genau wie die Intros, schickt uns zwei Wunder, die ihr erlebt habt, wenn ihr zwei Wunder erlebt habt.
Aber kurze Wunder.
Ja, ja.
Zwei kurze Wunder, bitte wenn es geht.
Haltet euch bitte kurz, ey.
Ja.
Riemann-Hypothese, gut, dass du sagst, es geht mit grossen, riesigen Schritten voran tatsächlich.
In Nature.com war diese Woche ein Artikel.
Aber da bin ich immer so skeptisch.
Es geht mit grossen Schritten in der Mathematik voran.
Take das mal with a grain of salt. Ja. Wenn ihr versteht, was ich meine, wenn ihr Englisch sprecht. Also die Schritte streben gegen Unendlichkeit. Und hier heißt es, after shocking the mathematics community with a major result in 2013. Mehr London, mehr London. Yi Tang Zhang now says he has solved an analog of the celebrated Riemann hypothesis. Also es geht weiter. Er hat einen Analog gelöst. Und da sagen wir herzlichen Glückwunsch. Toll gemacht. Die Podcast-Ufo-Tasse kommt für dich nach Hause. 16 Euro Merch-Shop-Gutschein und Sticker. Du bist im Exklusiv-Podcast-Ufo-Club. Club-exklusive Club-Mitgliedschaft. Herzlichen Glückwunsch an Yi Tang Zhang für diesen. Der hat 2013 schon mal einen Knüller rausgehauen und jetzt geht's weiter. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Die Tasse ist auf dem Weg zu dir. Das machen wir wirklich. Wir schicken ihm die das Podcast, eine Podcasts-Sofotasse, die es nicht gibt.
Doch, wir hätten doch mal eine Tasse.
Wo ist er denn unterwegs? University of California, Santa Barbara.
Wollen wir ihn nicht schicken? Es war ein großes Thema hier. Er ist nicht zwangsläufig ein Hörer von uns, aber er hat das Thema weitergebracht. We don't know.
Santa Barbara. Da war ich mal. Was kostet das? Das ist das Problem wahrscheinlich. Santa Barbara Versand. Also wenn ich 150 Euro auf der Straße finde, dann können wir das machen. Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir noch Tassen haben, ehrlich gesagt. Ich weiß auch nicht genau. Wir horchen mal nach und dann schicken wir dem eine Tasse. Als Dankeschön, dass er mit grossen Schritten, was auch immer das heißen mag, dürfen wir auch nicht verändern diesen Quote. Schritte größer null, würde ich sagen. Das ist das Mindeste, was sein muss. Und dann können wir ihn vielleicht motivieren. Aber ich finde, das ist ja immer gefährlich, wenn so die Medien schon draufspringen, so ist auf dem Weg, sie zu lösen, kurz davor sie zu lösen, der Druck steigt enorm. Der Druck steigt enorm.
Das ist die Frage, behindert das nicht eher, als dass es hilft.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Das ist eine richtig gute Frage.
Puh, Gott sei Dank.
Gott sei Dank fiel mir eine gute Frage ein.
Ja, das ist so wie, ich meine, bei Schach steht dann so drei Züge bis matt und du, ich sehe es nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber das berückt mich ja auch.
Grossmeister finden manchmal nicht mal, aber gut, da sind das so Ultra-Blitz-Partien, Bullet, was auch immer, in Mathe in eins. Bullet! Bullet, Bullet, das ist auch ein tolles Wort, Bullet. Da muss man sich irgendwann mal entscheiden, Bullet ist das Schnellste, dann kommt Blitz, dann kommt Rapid, dann kommt Classical. Also du hast dich zwischen, wie würdest du ordnen die Begriffe nach Geschnelligkeit? Ordne Bullet, Blitz und Rapid nach Geschwindigkeit. Ich würde sagen, Rapid ist das Langsamste, dann kommt Bullet, dann kommt Blitz, das ist das Schnellste. Blitz ist am schnellsten. Blitz ist doch deutlich schneller als Bullet, weil es Licht ist. Ja, definitiv, klar. Ja, ist es nicht. Bullet ist schneller als Blitz. Blitzpartie? Das ist halt, wenn du halt zu schnell zu hoch greifst. Wenn du halt sofort sagst, boah, der Film war ultra gut. So, und dann denkst du dir, oh shit, dann schaust du nächste Woche das nächste Flimmer-Filmchen an und dann sagst du, fuck, der war noch besser als Ultra. Und dann musst du irgendwie Hyper oder Trillionen Likes oder sowas. Das ist halt echt immer nervig. Du musst manchmal auch tief anfangen. Du musst richtig tief anfangen. Das ist ein richtig guter Punkt jetzt gerade, den du machst. Ja, du musst, so den ersten Film, den man jemals gesehen hat, so das erste Musical, muss man eher sagen, ich geb dir mal eine vier. Eine vorsichtige vier. Auch wenn man halt schon beim ersten Mal Hamilton gesehen hat. Du musst sagen, mal eine dreieinhalb. So, geht nicht. Genau, im schlimmsten Fall hast du halt eine sehr strenge Skala. Aber es macht nicht Hamilton schlechter, weil du alle anderen nur einen halben Stern gibst. Ja, das ist ja auch die alte Frage, ob du ... Wie gut ist Hamilton, ist die älteste Frage. Die glaube ich auch, älter noch als das Hydra-Problem. Wie gut ist Hamilton wirklich ... Aber die Frage ist, wie siehst du denn eine Eins- bis Zehner-Skala? Sagst du, die ist gleich verteilt? Also jede Note muss gleich oft vorkommen. Oder würdest du sagen, die ist normal verteilt, dass Zehn und Eins haben die wenigsten und die meisten sind so fünf? So wie so eine Glockenkurve. Das Ding ist ja, das ist ein großes Problem, was du da ansprichst, bei Internetbewertungen, auch gerade beim Fünf-Sterne-Ding und so. Man gibt ja selten die Höchstpunktzahl. Ich würde sagen, die Viersterne sind bei Fünf-Sterne-Bewertungen überrepräsentiert. Ja, die Viersterne sind die Fünf-Sterne der Fünf-Sterne-Kategorie. Richtig, genau. Aber dann ist die Kategorie kompletter Unsinn. Die Zehn-Sterne-Kategorie bei Letterboxd und so was wurde dann Filmebewertung, das ist ja auch für den Unsinn. Und deswegen sage ich, es ist doch besser zu denken, wenn du sagst F Sterne, 20% aller Filme sollen fünf Sterne bekommen. 20% vier, 20% drei, 20% zwei, 20% eins. Weil dann bist du nämlich auch bereit, die fünf rauszurücken. Aber so, ja, es werden ja nicht 20% supergute, perfekte Filme rausgebracht. Ja, aber es ist ja alles eine Relation zueinander. So, wenn du generell keine Filme, vielleicht magst du keine Filme und dann kannst du ja nicht allen nur maximal zwei Sterne geben.
Dann solltest du den Kritikerberuf überdenken. Du musst ja schon in dem Genre Film gucken, wo du bist, weil dann fängst du nämlich an zu denken, ah, ich habe schon lange keine Fünfer mehr gegeben und gibst mir wieder eine Fünfer oder ich muss auch mal wieder eine Einser geben oder sowas. Und dann, glaube ich, gibt so eine Skala erst wirklich Sinn.
Oder wie?
Ich bin immer so genervt von diesen Skalen, von Leuten, die bei eins bis zehn eigentlich immer nur sieben und acht sagen. Wo man denkt, ja, du hast entweder einfach keine Meinung oder wir können auch eine eins bis zwei Skala machen. Gut, schlecht, können wir alles machen. Ich habe Zeit, wir setzen uns hin und wir gehen nochmal alle Filme durch und du gibst mir ein oder zwei Sterne. Das ist wirklich kein Problem. Ich habe die Zeit, ich habe wirklich nichts zu tun. Ich habe den ganzen Tag frei, ich sitze nur rum und niese und wir können das gerne machen. Ich habe mich verschrieben, die nischigsten Probleme der Welt zu tun. Ja, aber die muss auch jemand angehen. Nee, ich gebe dir da auch völlig recht, ich glaube, das ist auch ein großes Problem, Internetbewertungen. Mit dem grossen Zusatz, dass man ja auch nur bewertet, wenn man nicht gerade hauptgruppliche Kritiker ist, bewerte ich doch nur, wenn etwas sehr, sehr gut oder sehr, sehr schlecht ist. Das stimmt. Es gibt aber auch Leute, ich bin ja häufig auf Amazon unterwegs, es gibt Leute, die bewerten generell und da gibt es dann so herrliche Bewertungen in drei von fünf Sternen, ich kann nichts zu dem Produkt sagen, weil es ein Geschenk war. Also die Person hat es gekauft, verschenkt und dann hat Amazon gesagt, ja und wie fanden sie das jetzt?
naja aber ja also ich habe es gar nicht selber benutzt
aber die Selbstbewusstsein dann drei Sterne selbstverständlich zu geben
ja das ist dann so
und die Herrscher denken so
what nein, wir haben nicht drei Sterne, das ist nicht gut
das ist nicht gut, drei Sterne sind echt schlecht
das sind die zwei Sterne selbstverständlich zu geben. Ja, das ist dann so ... Und die Hersteller denken so, what? Nein, wir haben nicht drei Sterne. Das ist nicht gut. Das ist nicht gut. Drei Sterne sind echt schlecht. Das sind die zwei Sterne der Internet fünf Sterne. Das stimmt, ja. Ja, es ist schwierig. Nee, aber ich würde ja ... Meine Google-Bewertungen ... Weil immer wenn ich richtig, richtig sauer bin auf Cafés, Restaurants oder so was, einmal wurde ich so schlecht behandelt neulich, dann ist meine stärkste Waffe, die ich besitze, in meinem Kopf eine einsterne Bewertung bei Google zu geben. Was bedeutet, du wurdest so schlecht behandelt? Jetzt bin ich wirklich gespannt. Jetzt bin ich wirklich gespannt. Was für ein Stefan Tietze ein Ich wurde richtig schlecht behandelt ist. Aber jetzt ist die Gefahr, uns im Falsch rüber zu kommen. Ach wirklich? Ach so. Ach ja, dann sag's lieber nicht. Doch, ich werde ... Nee, dann erzähl's lieber nicht. Aber jetzt muss ich's ja sagen. Damit die Leute deinen Anspruch nicht falsch einschätzen. Pass auf, ich sass in einem Café, es war nicht sonderlich voll. Ich habe super häufig gewollt, ich bedient werden. Wir waren in einer Vierergruppe. Garçon. Und ich habe super, super freundlich, habe ich immer aufgezeigt und gesagt, kann man bestellen. Und es ist wirklich ungelogen, eine halbe Stunde oder sowas saßen wir da und wurden nicht bedient. Irgendwann wurde es dann auch so ein Gag ein bisschen in der Gruppe. Wir wurden nicht bedient. Dann ist jemand aus der Gruppe, ich natürlich nicht, weil ich mich nicht traue, aufgestanden, zu einem der Kellner gegangen und hat gesagt, können wir was bestellen? Sehr super freundlich und diese Person wurde ermahnt, jemand darf sich eigentlich einfach hinsetzen, sondern man soll vorne stehen bleiben, was nicht bestand, und hin platziert werden. Sonst könnte sich ja jeder hinsetzen, irgendwo, und Anarchie würde ausbrechen, würde ich in Frage stellen, ob denn das System zusammenbricht. Dann hieß es so, ja, sorry, wir haben uns tausendmal entschuldigt, dass wir uns einfach hingesetzt hätten. Dann kam der Kellner dann irgendwann und hat gesagt, ja, aber der Tisch ist ja noch, da waren noch Sachen drauf, von Leuten, die da vorgesessen haben. Der Tisch sei dreckig, ich könnte ja nicht hier hinsetzen, wir haben die gleiche Ansage nochmal bekommen, Tisch sei noch dreckig, wir sollen uns bitte woanders hinsetzen, an einen anderen Tisch, der schon gemacht wurde, wir so, ja, ist kein Problem, wir haben uns unsere Sachen hingestellt und so, ist ja kein Problem, wenn es jetzt noch ein bisschen dauert, Sie können ja die Sachen wegstellen, wir haben es ja nicht eilig, wir würden nur gerne in näherer Zukunft noch etwas konsumieren. Und dann hat er gesagt, mein Gott, ihr seid doch wirklich kompliziert. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ist kein Problem, dann lass es einfach gehen. Und dann wollte ich gehen, weil wir hätten dann nochmal aufstehen sollen, uns an einen anderen Tisch setzen sollen, der schon genehm sei, der war aber super eng und kacke. Und das fand ich dann, ich fand die Anhäufung der Sachen plus die Attitude nicht so geil. Und bin dann gegangen, sind wir gegangen, und ich wusste nicht wohin mit meinem Unwohlsein und hab dann entschieden, eine Einsteinebewertung zu geben. Mit dem Verweis, dass es mir ... Am Abend, du hast diesen Graben den ganzen Tag in dir getragen? Nee, nee, nee. Auf dem Weg zu dem anderen Kaffee, was dann viel cooler war,
habe ich direkt die Ein-Sterne-Bewertung gegeben und war dann fein.
Also das heißt, deine Gruppe hat auch mitbekommen,
dass du jetzt eine Ein-Sterne-Bewertung gibst.
Das hast du gross gemacht? Ja, klar.
Hast du es richtig aufgetragen? Naja, ich habe
allen kommuniziert, natürlich.
Und dann war das
andere Lokal viel cooler.
Und dann war meine Bewertung in etwa wie folgt. Beim Café XY wird man so schlecht behandelt, dass man sich gezwungen sieht, die besseren Restaurants in der Nachbarschaft oder so zu finden. Ich erinnere mich nicht genau an den Wortlaut, aber habe ich so einen kleinen Augenzwinker an den reiserischen Kommentar geschrieben. Wow. Du bist ganz schön kompliziert, Stefan. Ehrlich gesagt, es geht. Es war so, es war, ich verstehe das von außen, es ist auch so ein bisschen, man muss dabei gewesen an Geschichte, aber es war, so unfreundlich wurden wir behandelt und so. Und das war nicht, weil man jetzt wahnsinnig viel erwartet hätte oder sowas, sondern man wollte ein paar Kölsch trinken. Und dann fand ich halt dieses von oben herab und dann an und von A nach B geschickt zu werden und so. Und wenn man halt freundlich ist, finde ich, kann man auch erwarten, dass man ähnlich freundlich zurückbehandelt wird. Das war super schwierig da. Ich weiß, es ist ein scheiß Job vielleicht auch einfach. Ja, und wenn die sich ein System überlegt haben, die setzen nicht hin, wo du nicht hinsetzen kannst.
Haben wir auch angeboten, ordnen wir uns gerne hinterher, haben tausend mal entschuldigt, aber ich finde, dann geht es auch irgendwann, sollte es dann nicht mehr um das Prinzip gehen. Aber meinst du, die haben euch absichtlich so lange warten lassen, weil ihr euch selbstständig hingesetzt habt und die euch bestrafen wollen? Ja, ja, klar, ja, genau. Also hat er auch zugegeben. In meinem Herzen, in meinem tiefen, menschenverachtenden Herz, kann ich das schon nachvollziehen, dass wenn man sich so ein System überlegt und dann machen die einfach, was sie wollen und dann sagt man, nee, wisst ihr was, dann nicht. Und dann wenn sie sagt, ja dann, weil es ist vielleicht unangenehm, das abzuräumen, wenn da noch Leute sitzen und so, aber ich kann natürlich verstehen, dein Gram und ich meine, du hast jetzt den Sanktstatus und die Leute sollten es besser wissen und ja, das stimmt schon. Vielleicht können wir für nächste Woche die Gegendarstellung des Kellners auch mal einholen, dass wir das wirklich mal gegenüberstellen können. Ich bin gar kein Fan davon. Das ist meine zweite Beschwerde, meine zweite Einsternbewertung. Die andere war einfach nur, der Kellner ist ein Arschloch, ein Stern, das hatte ich ja auch schon mal. Aber diese Geschichte folgt ja irgendwann anders, wenn sich mein Ruhm wieder erholt hat. Ich bin ja auch kein Fan davon. Ich weiß, ich habe auch Freunde, die in der Gastro arbeiten. Ich weiß, das ist super nerviger. Du hast The Bear gesehen. Ich habe The Bear gesehen. Es ist halt einfach teilweise auch ein Kackjob. Leute sind Arschlöcher. Aber wir waren super, super freundlich und wurden super, super hart mit uns ins Gericht gegangen. Und ich finde, du hast total recht, wenn man sich ein Restaurant, ein System überlegt, wir gehen ja da hin als Kunden und haben uns ja auch diesem System unterzuordnen. Aber es gibt ja dann den Weg, wie führst du das aus als Restaurant? Und dann schreib doch bitte, wie alle anderen Restaurants oder Cafés der Welt, stellt doch vorne ein Schild hin, please wait to be seated. Das ist ja überall, wenn man das will, dann muss man das ja auch umsetzen. Du kannst ja nicht erwarten, das ist ein super offener Platz gewesen, wo von allen Seiten Leute reinkamen. Ich bin auf der Seite des Kellners. Why, though? Ich bin auf der anderen Seite. Ich habe das Gefühl, du ahnst das Augenräumen von Leuten und bist so Fähnchen im Wind. Es kommt halt auch darauf an, wie man es sagt, die Musik macht den Ton. Und das dann so sagt, ja, setzt euch doch einfach da drüben hin. Das war nicht der Ton. Und dann so, nee, wollen wir jetzt doch nicht, da kann ich schon verstehen. Das war nicht der Ton. Ich meine, er hat es euch angeboten, dann nochmal das System zu korrigieren, zu sagen, nee, dann setzt euch doch da drüber, da ist ja der Tisch schon fertig. Aber es macht ja überhaupt keinen Sinn. Warum sollen wir dann andere Familien schon? Aber was meinst du mit, wir hatten unsere Sachen schon dastehen? Ich meine, da hatte jeder einen Turnister, einen Regenschirm. Es war so ein Samstag, wo man halt da noch einkaufen war und so, Leute haben Taschen dabei. Taschen. Ja, viele Leute waren da. So, manche haben, ich finde das unfair. Naja, es ist was anderes, also wenn der jetzt wirklich, keine Ahnung, da der in Kinderwagen steht und die Poolnudel und irgendwie da schon aufgemacht oder sowas und dass man dann sagt, naja, wir haben uns jetzt schon hier bequem gemacht, aber wenn du da irgendwie mit deiner Juppi-Zara-Tüte denn da ankommst, wo du deine neue Sonnenbrille gekauft hast, ich weiss auch nicht, was das für ein Ort war, wo es jetzt sonnig ist um die Uhrzeit. War es im Ausland? Nein, nein. Nein, das war hier in Kölle. Also, aber es ist doch bescheuert. Ich meine, wir haben ja dann vier Leute müssen dann aufstehen, plus dann standen schon andere Leute da an diesem anderen Tisch, wo er uns dann hinverwiesen hat. Die standen, das heißt die haben verstanden, dass man sich nicht direkt hinsetzt. Nein, die haben sich da einfach so davor platziert und wollten beinahe. Davor platziert. Die sind gerade gekommen, gehen zum Tisch, sind bereits dabei, Dinge, Taschen werden wieder hingestellt, viele Taschen im Spiel, sind im Begriff sich hinzusetzen. Das Taschen-Outlet direkt um die Ecke und alle voll bepackt. Wir haben das. Sind im Begriff, sich hinzusetzen. Er verweist uns dahin, war auch schon angepisst auf diese Leute. Ja, okay. Das System wurde nicht verstanden. Wir sollen alle unsere Sachen nehmen. Vor allem, es war ja eher, auch aus dem Service-Gedanken haben wir gesagt, nee, ist gar kein Problem, dass der Tisch noch dreckig ist.
Wir können einfach hier sitzen bleiben, es ist ja gar kein Stress, wenn das jemand abräumt und so. Der muss ja eh sauber gemacht werden, verstehst du?
Ja, aber es ist ein Unterschied, ob da Leute sitzen oder nicht, das kann ich schon verstehen. Das ist so, wie wenn jemand dann so kehrt, während der andere auf der Couch sitzt und so.
Das ist ja die ganze Zeit. Also es waren so drei Sachen plus diese ganze unfreundliche Attitude, die mich dazu verleidete. Und alle waren auch sauer.
Es ist eine sehr gute Frage. Also es waren so drei Sachen plus diese ganze unfreundliche Attitude, die mich das verleidert hat. Und alle waren auch sauer. Ich bin auch gar nicht so anspruchsvoll. Du hast dich ein bisschen hochpeitschen lassen von den anderen, habe ich das Gefühl. Kann es sein, dass in der Gruppe da auch ein bisschen eine Dynamik drin war? Nee, Gruppe war angenehm. Es war auch die ganze Zeit eigentlich eine lustige Stimmung darüber, dass man gerade nicht bedient wurde. Du kannst ja drüber lachen. Du bist ja jemand, du kannst ja drüber lachen. Ich kann ja auch in dem Moment nicht drüber lachen. Du kannst ja auch über einen verspäteten Bus dich nochmal kaputt lachen. Ich verstehe das schon. Deswegen wollte ich das gar nicht erzählen, weil es natürlich immer unsympathisch ist, sich über Servicepersonal aufzuregen und so. Auf der anderen Seite, weiß ich nicht. Kann man doch einfach ein freundliches Miteinander
propagieren oder nicht?
Ja, ja, absolut.
Dass du jetzt aus Prinzip dann so die Seite einnimmst.
Ich würde halt gerne auch die andere Seite hören.
Vielleicht kannst du mir nach der Aufnahme
den Namen des Lokals sagen,
dann werde ich die Gegendarstellung einholen
und dann können wir das vielleicht nochmal
gegenüberstellen, um das
Ganze nochmal aufzurollen, weil ich finde, ab einem gewissen Punkt muss auch die Gegenseite zu Wort kommen. Naja. Einfach damit man sich ein neutrales Urteil bilden kann. Ich finde es eigentlich auch ziemlich lustig. Ich behaupte mal, pessimistischerweise, dass sich der Kellner nicht bereit erklären wird, da zu stellen. Ach, okay. Also das ist eine Unterstellung.
Du meinst, dass er so viel Dreck am Stecken hat, dass er wirklich dem Inwissige... Vielleicht können wir
Thais einfach mal ganz kurz
ihren Fall fallen lassen
und wir gehen über zu einem
anderen. Vielleicht wäre das
eine Möglichkeit. Du meinst, dass sie da anfängt zu arbeiten,
um zu wissen, wie der hinter den Kulissen ist? Ja.
Thais Maulwurf.
Finde ich eine gute Idee.
Vielleicht können wir der ganzen Sache auf den Grund gehen,
aber so bleibt erst mal stehen.
Heiligenantrag offen,
Sankt Stephanslied offen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, findest du,
warum hast du mich gerade so hart in die Mangel genommen?
Weil du die Einschränkungsbewertung
für eine harte Gegenmaßnahme dann hältst?
Ich sag nur so,
wenn ich einen Kaffee aufmachen würde, dann weißiss ich, dass ich super pedantische Regeln hätte und mir genau überlege, wie das alles funktionieren soll und mich ärgern würde. Aber du würdest auch die pedantisch umsetzen, du würdest die nicht Larifari umsetzen. Nee, genau. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es als Kellner super nervig ist, Sachen abzuräumen und da zu wischen, während der Leute sitzen. Sorry, es gehört leider einfach zum Job, dass die Tischten sauber gemacht werden. Ja, man kann es ja verbessern, man kann es ja verbessern. Man kann überlegen, okay, dann machen wir es folgendermaßen. Die Leute werden immer an den Tisch hingeführt, der schon fertig ist und dann in der Zwischenzeit kann man den anderen abräumen. So, dann kann ich verstehen, dass wenn man sich das überlegt, dass das dann schwierig wird. Das ist so wie wenn ich ein Kino aufmachen würde, wo man nicht reden darf und dann nicht sagt, bitte nicht reden und so, ja, das steht ja nirgend. Aber das macht die ganze Experience-Kaffee nicht so gut. Ich bin zu 70 Prozent auf deiner Seite. Aber ich versuche mich auch, um in die Gegenseite rein zu versetzen. Ich finde nur die Vehemenz, in der du so vorauseilenden Gastropersonal gerade einnimmst schwierig, vor allem in der Hinsicht, dass meine Bestrafung ja relativ smooth ist.
Aber da könnt ihr auch mal sagen, wenn ihr aus der Gastfizienne kommt, wie sehr stören einen schnell Bewertungen.
Gerne, schreibt das gerne auf. Ich verstehe auch, dass der Punkt, wo er sagt, seid ihr nervig, so das ist dann zu viel.
Da ist dann der Punkt der Professionalität erreicht, wo das dann einfach nicht geht.
Inwiefern das dann nachvollziehbar ist, ist dann natürlich eine andere Frage, das fand ich auch ungerechtfertigt.
Ich meine, ich kenne dich auch privat,
kompliziert trifft es gut.
Ja, genau.
Komplizierter Mensch. Also,
okay.
Ich versuche meinen Ruf jetzt wieder herzustellen
in der Öffentlichkeit, sorry für diese
ja, ich weiß, da bin ich ausgeflippt
mit meiner Einsteinebewertung an diesem
sehr busy Lokal. Einmal komplett ausgerastet. Und jetzt ist es aber wieder in der Waage, du hast zwei kleinen Mädchen das Teilen beigebracht und Du hast es nicht mehr, sondern es ist nicht mehr, sondern es ist nicht mehr, sondern es ist nicht mehr, sondern esaten. Ja, genau. Nicht, dass ihr jetzt denkt, das ist offensichtlich ein Heiliger. Nein, nein, nein, auch ich habe meine Ausbrüche, auch ich habe meine... Und das gehört zur Geschichte, das gehört zur Moral. Ja, ja. Ich bin gespannt, wie ihr das da draußen seht. Richtet. Richtet über mein Haupt. Vielleicht können wir nächste Woche das Ganze ein bisschen aufklären. Bis dahin wünschen wir euch eine schöne Woche. Haut rein. Ich will nicht mit dieser Anekdoten, die ich... Nein! Ich hebe ab! Du kannst noch bleiben, ist mir egal, aber ich hebe ab. Ich stelle jetzt noch rum eine halbe Stunde und das ist zu erklären. Wie geht das denn hier? Ziehst du immer den Hebel oder wie machst du das? Ich habe das so eingerichtet, dass wir zu zweit abheben müssen. Wir müssen beide sagen, wir heben ab. Was ist denn Sprachgesteuer? Sprachgesteuer, das sind alles Bremsen. Das sind alles Bremsen? Ich saß noch nie rechts.
Ich weiss, ich weiss. Der Gashebel gibt es ja nicht, das ist sprachgesteuert.
Kommst du rein, bitte.
Ich möchte nur sagen, ich bin ein guter Mensch, hab mich weiterhin lieb.
Ich will zu sehr geliebt werden dafür, dass ich jetzt mit dieser Geschichte aufhören will.
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir jetzt auch keine Zeit mehr.
Wir wünschen nachher eine schöne Woche. Macht's gut.
Macht's gut, we machen's gut. Tschau.